bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue l'émission où l'on débat chaque jour
en direct de l'actualité la plus
brillante avec nos quatre invités nous
allons nous intéresser aujourd'hui à la
droite est assez aux remous qu'a créé
les positions de sens commun ce
mouvement qui appartient aux
républicains et qui a donné le sentiment
à tort ou à raison de tendre la main au
front national
était ce une faute une erreur de
stratégie ou même une erreur de
l'idéologie nous en parlerons nous
parlerons aussi de l'avenir des
allocations familiales
il ya un grand débat en ce moment pour
savoir s'ils doivent rester universelle
ou bien s'il faut les réserver aux
familles les plus défavorisées
ce serait un changement de doctrine mais
y en avait déjà eu lieu en 2015 est ce
que ça va continuer et puis toujours les
sujets de société
l'égalité homme-femme jusqu'où doit-elle
aller marlène schiappa et muriel
pénicaud que vous voyez à l'antenne ont
proposé dans un guide pour l'égalité
hommes-femmes dans les pme d'installer
l'écriture inclusive parce que c'est une
vraie ou une fausse bonne idée
et puis nous commencerons par parler de
richard ferrand le député chef du groupe
la république en mars à l'assemblée
nationale à la suite de la décision du
parquet de rennes de classer sans suite
les poursuites qu'ils avaient été qui
aurait pu être lancées contre lui nous
avons parlé de tous ces sujets avec
françois-xavier bellamy bonsoir soyez
les bienvenus dans point de vue
vous êtes maire adjoint de versailles
professeur de philosophie votre dernier
livre à la jeunesse les publier chez
librio et vous avez aussi publié un
article remarqué sur le figaro voc sur
la pma pour toutes qu'ils étaient sous
titré dernière frontière avant le
transhumanisme bonsoir eric decouty en
soi directeur délégué de la rédaction de
marianne votre magazine s'intéresse
cette semaine au home and had et alors
difficulté on va voir à l'antenne la
couverture de marianne paru aujourd'hui
la révolte des malades et vous nous
parler également de la vigilant de la
violence a oui alors un débat passionné
rue des basques à tour de la violence
est ce que la violence peut tout
justifier un climat doux au frais ça
vaut le détour
absolument et à ceux qui s'intéressent à
ça je vous renvoie au grand jury de
dimanche sur rtl lci le figaro ou non un
flic tron jean luc mélenchon vous avez
compris peut-être
bonsoir un jour un grand vous êtes le
président de dentsu consulting expertise
de votre cabinet sce l'influencent
stratégie d'influencé réputation des
entreprises sur internet et ça c'est
tout à fait ça et carl meeus bonjour
jean karl vous êtes le rédacteur en chef
politique du figaro magazine et vous
signez le dossier de couverture de cette
semaine du fig mag sur la nouvelle vie
des politiques vous vous êtes intéressé
à tous ces gens qui ont tourné la page
pour toujours pour quelques temps ça
dépend des fois et qui sont du mal à le
reconnaître que c'est pour toujours
voilà et qui sent qu'ils sont partis
vers d'autres horizons en particulier
professionnel je vous propose de nous
intéresser pour commencer à richard
ferrand le procureur de la république de
brest a publié il ya quelques minutes
c'est un communiqué expliquant que les
il n'y aurait pas de suite aux
poursuites contre richard ferrand je
vous rappelle en deux 2 minutes le
dossier richard ferrand directeur
général d mutuel de bretagne avaient
installé des bureaux de sa société dans
un immeuble acquis par sa compagne y
avait-il abus de confiance non a dit le
parquet il y at il eu escroquerie non
ati a dit le parquet y at il eu prise
illégale d'intérêt dans la mesure où une
mutuelle même si une entreprise qui
n'est pas public a quand même une
mission de service public est bien là le
procureur de la république a dit de
toute façon il ya prescription donc même
s'il y avait pu avoir quelque chose il
est trop tard pour qu'ils aient
d'éventuelles poursuites
françois-xavier bellamy est ce que c'est
une décision qui vous paraît juste
si fier celle du parquet je suis pas je
ne suis pas juriste et je ne vais pas me
prononcer sur le point de droit qui est
temps qui est en question je crois que
les magistrats font leur travail et je
n'ai pas la compétence pour pour
commenter cette décision sur le plan du
droit simplement est ce qu'on peut
constater c'est que on a vécu une année
qui a été marquée par une aspiration
profonde des français a une éthique de
leurs dirigeants politiques et que c'est
largement à la faveur de cette
aspiration qu emmanuel macron à
installer le nouveau monde dont il nous
parlait ce qui est très frappant et ceux
qui je dois le dire me paraît absolument
révoltant c'est que richard ferrand
indépendamment de la façon dont on peut
qualifier juridiquement les questions
qui sont en jeu étant donné que tous les
faits sont avérés et qu'ils ne sont pas
démenti alors même qu'il y a de toute
évidence une stratégie d'enrichissement
personnel de son 200 foyers et richard
ferrand et pu être propulsé chef du
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale sans qu'aucun autre candidat
ne se soit présenté
évidemment sur ordre de l'elysée et pour
sécuriser encore le vote des
parlementaires avec un vote à main levée
c'était quelques jours seulement après
l'installation de cette nouvelle
majorité
et de fait je crois que ce jour là les
parlementaires du groupe de la
république en marche ont signé leur
impuissance politique pour le
quinquennat qui venaient en admettant
qu'ils accepteraient absolument
n'importe quoi parce que ce qui se joue
c'est effectivement absolument n'importe
quoi j'ai j'ai dit pendant la campagne
des présidentielles à quel point je
trouvais les âges les actes de françois
fillon révoltant et je les dis alors
même que j'ai suis engagé à droite je
les dis parce que je fais partie de de
ceux qui aspirent à voir la politique
retrouver ses lettres de noblesse et et
qui aspire à une exemplarité de nos
dirigeants
j'ai du mal à comprendre que à la faveur
de ski de ce procès public a été fait à
françois fillon de façon légitime au
cours de la campagne on puisse
aujourd'hui se retrouver avec face à
nous des élus qui sont aussi engagés
dans des affaires de corruption pourtant
largement similaire
du coup tu as tout aussi sévère ce que
dit françois que les bellamy est assez
juste en partie en même temps moi je
trouve assez inquiétant dire
qu'aujourd'hui notre vie politique
depuis 25 ans elle est marquée par une
succession d'affaires et à tort ou à
raison le le juge de paix de la moralité
publique c'est le magistrat c'est la
justice et on a vu des gens condamnés à
vous exécuter leur peine et revenir en
politique des gens qui étaient qu'il y
avait des soupçons extrêmement lourd
mais où la justice se promenant c'est
avec un non lieu et il revenait comme si
de rien n'était on peut contester ça
mais au moins c'est la frontière entre
ce qui est de la morale et ce qui est de
la justice et on considère
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le juge d'une
certaine façon qui dit si un homme
politique peut revenir ou pas dans le
jeu politique et ce qui se passe avec
françois ferrand je pense que richard
ferrand pardo mois mais pendant environ
un peu c'est que il ya une dimension
morale qui est incontestable est
aujourd'hui richard ferrand il est est
ce qu'il est discrédité
je n'en sais rien mais en tous les cas
le boulet moral de cette affaire restera
comme il restera présente d'autres élus
mais ça vaut le coup qu'on mette de la
morale dans la politique est ce que ça
vous paraît légitime parce que ça me
paraît absolument légitime qui est de la
morale en politique enfin moi ça fait 20
ans que je dis ça j'ai suivi longtemps
les affaires et je pense que c'est
indispensable
et en même temps il faut bien une
barrière une frontière à ne pas franchir
et c'est le juge qui veulent dire vous
savez dans les pays du nord ça ne se
passe pas comme ça c'est à dire que il
ya eu un ministre qui utilise sa carte
pour payer ses courses parce qu'elle n'a
pas le temps elle est prise elle est
démissionner immédiatement
c'est un principe moral la justice n'a
rien à voir moi je ne suis pas pour ça
je trouve que c'est assez juste qui à un
moment il ya la règle et il ya le juge
le procureur ou un autre en tous les cas
qui dit il ya eu franchissement de la
ligne rouge ou pas et on est obligé de
se conforter de se conformer à ça parce
que sinon on est dans l'application de
la morale mais où la morale s'applique
me semble-t-il c'est sur les électeurs
c'est que il ya un moment c'est les
électeurs qui oui ou non disent s'il
sanctionne moralement richard ferrand
françois fillon ou un autre maintenant
ma grande je disais votre spécialité
c'est la réputation a plutôt des
entreprises mais
que quand tu as un responsable politique
ou une institution d'ailleurs a été mêlé
à des affaires même si la justice dit
qu'il faut s'arrêter le mal est fait en
quelque sorte la trace la réputation et
durablement entacher pour une
institution ou une personne qu'il ya le
temps de la justice
et puis il ya le temps de la prise de
décision par les français et finalement
si on regarde la sphère ferron avec eux
ce qu'ils disent sur les réseaux sociaux
on s'aperçoit que c'est celui qui est
probablement le plus critique et de
l'ensemble des députés de la république
aux marches c'est principalement parce
que il était le chantre de finalement
d'une certaine moralité et que forcément
il est il est tombé entre le 22 et le 29
mai suite à la révélation du canard sur
ses sauts montage de financiers on se
souvient qu'à l'époque il était ministre
ce que je parle sous votre contrôle
qu'avec qu'il a démissionné pour ensuite
être nommé président du groupe est ce
qui est intéressant c'est que autant on
a relevé un pic de messages entre le 22
et le 29 mai presque 165 mille messages
et qui étaient majoritairement à
tonalité négative 35% autant depuis
finalement la sphère est passé et si je
reprends les comment dire les deux
dernières semaines on a à peine trois
mille cinq cents messages qui traitent
du sujet richard ferrand donc là
évidemment on va assister à un pic parce
que la décision de justice elle est
relayée
mais les les français ont déjà pris leur
décision ils ont déjà finalement jugé
avant la justice et du coup ils sont
passés au sujet sur et ils sont passés
aux sujets suivants carl meeus quel peut
être l'impact politique de cette affaire
le retour de richard ferrand
gouvernement vous l'avez dit vous-même
il a dû démissionner à la suite de
de la faire avant même d'être mis en
examen
alors qu'avant la règle c'était si un
ministre est bien en examen il
démissionne parce que c'est plus simple
pour se défendre
là dans le cas de richard ferrand et
dans le cas d'ailleurs de de françois
bayrou et marielle de sarnez c'est avant
même qu'ils aient des mises en examen le
simple fait qu'ils aient des soupçons et
tout ça donc ça crée là peut-être une
petite difficulté donc la logique
maintenant serait qu'il puisse revenir
au gouvernement et s'attaqueront avec
l'huile emmerdant mais oui je veux vous
dire que autant il était content de
retrouver un rôle politique à la
présidence du groupe temps c'est pas ça
qui le faisait rêver
diriger un groupe à l'international
c'est bien diriger le groupe en marche
c'est compliqué parce que ces gens-là
les 300 et quelques députés en marche
n'ont pas grand chose en commun un
certain qu'ils sont un peu de gauche
l'autre un peu de droite
difficile de trouver une unité et c'est
pas très valorisant revenir au
gouvernement oui c'est son souhait est
ce que ça va être celui d' emmanuel
macron c'est pas sûr parce qu'au fond la
son gouvernement fonctionne bien il a
trouvé un certain équilibre il ya des
ministres qui commencent à émerger
est-ce qu'il faut refaire tout un petit
mécano parce qu'on sait très bien
comment ça commence qu'on commence à
dire on va faire un léger réaménagement
technique et on se retrouve finalement à
changer plus de choses donc est-ce que
emmanuel macron voudra rentrer dans ce
sujet là je pense qu'on aura la réponse
dimanche puisqu'il intervient la
télévision devrait conviennent pour ça
que j'avais bel ami sur cette notion de
morale
est-ce que dès lors qu'on n'a rien fait
d'illégal il n'est pas légitime que
richard ferrand puisse revenir au
gouvernement
attention la base de ce classement sans
suite ne consiste pas à affirmer que
richard ferrand n'a rien fait d'illégal
mais que si les faits illégaux ont été
commis ils sont prescrits de toute façon
et que ça ne justifie donc pas
l'ouverture d'une afin de les initier à
tous marqués par it is une fois la bonne
ambiance on a le barca dit non sur
l'escroquerie
le parquet dit non sur la précision la
prise illégale d'intérêt ou des
recruteurs
je suis président d'une mission locale
qui est un peu comme une mutuelle
beaucoup plus petit mais une association
je fais ça bénévolement je n'imagine pas
une seule seconde assumer moralement le
poids de ce qu'a fait richard ferrand
c'est à dire entre trois options d'achat
pour un bien immobilier monter une sci
spécifiquement emporté par sa compagne
pour acheter un bien
les parts de la sci ayant pris on estime
que 3000 pour cent de leur valeur après
l'opération entièrement financée par la
mutuelle qui le dirigeait je vois mal
comment on peut justifier des faits de
cette nature d'un point de vue moral
encore une fois je ne suis pas juriste
mais je crois que comme vous êtes
professeur de philosophie ça vous
intéresse avoir votre avis il me semble
que le disais à l'instant il est
absolument impossible de dissocier
l'exercice politique de la
responsabilité morale et c'est d'autant
plus impossible dans une période de
crise profonde où beaucoup de nos
concitoyens vont devoir subir des
décisions qui vont être éprouvante pour
eux d'un point de vue matériel
je crois qu'on a suffisamment répété
pendant la campagne présidentielle et
encore une fois à raison la
responsabilité première des responsables
politiques et d'être exemplaires dans
leur propre gestion des biens publics
dont ils ont la charge
je n'aimerais pas être blanchi en
quelque sorte par un communiqué qui dit
que la seule question concerne la nature
pénale
the lack tible c'est juste mais la
question c'est qui décident de quel
moment la morale publique a été franchie
c'est qu'à part les électeurs en
démocratie le président barack
paraissait la salle c'est le chef de
l'état c'est une mission symbolique dont
il est investi ce problème c'est qu'on
est champions de l'histoire aussi sur la
morale vous souvenez quand filon a été à
lui ses ennuis pendant la campagne
présidentielle
richard a été un des premiers à dire que
moralement c'était pas bien c'est ça
aussi qui comptent qui a compliqué moi
j'avais tendance à croire beaucoup à la
responsabilité a priori mais c'est mon
côté naïf et peut-être même enfantin de
croire à la responsabilité de chacun de
responsabilité de l'homme politique
surtout dans un discours on est
censément dans un dans un nouveau monde
avec chacun parce que là on voit quoi
avec richard ferrand on voit le vieux
monde
c'est le vieux monde qui revient c'est
les affaires anciennes ont depuis 25 ans
on a vu tous les uns les autres ici d
des hommes des femmes surtout des hommes
poursuivis par la justice et puis
revenir comme si de rien était qu'ils
soient de gauche ou de droite
et là c'est un peu ça moi je croirais
j'aimerais croire à la responsabilité de
chacun c'est à dire que après une
affaire quand bien même le parquet prend
une décision juridique qui fait sinon
qu'ils ne blanchit pas mais en tous les
cas qui fait table rase et bien ils ne
sortent de d'absence de discrétion
pendant un temps donc à la
responsabilité de chacun plus qu'une
responsabilité du président de la
république
de quel droit de quai auquel non c'est
très compliqué mais rappelle ana moura
rendriez richard ferrand au gouvernement
à la place du président de la république
ou non vous hésiteriez à deux voies non
je pense que je pense que les citoyens
ne comprendrais pas là aujourd'hui
je pense qu'ils auraient parce qu'à une
fausse pièce de c'est un peu c'est un
peu puéril mais de délai de décence
je pense que richard ferrand et par
françois ferrand devrait s'appliquer une
espèce de délai de décence et se faire
discret pendant un temps on oublie les
affaires s'oublie elle se sublime comme
d'autres choses et je pense que ça
devrait il devrait s'appliquer salle et
chantal ne dit si richard ferrand
revient en politique ce serait honteux
s'il revenait en politique pour avoir la
concordance des temps ayé n'a pas quitté
la paille et il le chante là nous parle
de nadar togo gouvernement et c'est raté
pour la discrétion il est ce soir
oui dans une chaîne de télévision
d'informations donc mais ce qui est
intéressant je trouve c'est que ça fait
on parle de nouveau monde on parle de
morale publique pendant toute la
campagne d'appareils essentiellement de
ça on a l'impression les uns les autres
ça fait on les voit les affaires des
filets depuis toutes ces années on a
malgré tout l'impression que rien ne
change et que on a beau tenir des
discours à un moment lors d'une campagne
électorale
eh bien on a l'impression que tout se
poursuit comme avant comme il ya 20 ans
comme il ya dix ans et plus encore eh
bien on en saura peut être un peu plus
ce soir effectivement avec
l'intervention de richard ferrand je
propose de nous intéresser à la droite
et à sens comme un sens commun vous
savez c'est ce mouvement qui fait partie
des républicains entendre on dit souvent
qu'il est l'émanation 6d juridique en
tout cas intellectuelle et morale de la
manif pour tous le président de sens
commun avait laissé entendre que
il pourrait y avoir un rapprochement sur
le plan des idées avec marion
maréchal-le pen sous la forme d'une
plateforme commune
et puis finalement il a démenti en
disant non ce n'est pas une main tendue
au front national
ces déclarations ont semé un certain
trouble je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction de laurent wauquiez le
président de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes qui est aussi comme nulle
désormais ne l'ignorent plus candidat à
la présidence des républicains il ya eu
des propos qui ont été beaucoup trop
léger un communiqué hier soir qui a été
fait pour le rectifier mais je suis
claire
s'il ya le moindre passage à l'acte ils
n'auront plus leur place chez les
républicains
notre famille a besoin de retrouver de
la clarté car mail pour la clarté qu'est
ce qui s'est passé à votre avis le le
président de sens commun il est il a
parlé trop vite il a été mal compris il
a fait une faute de débutant je vais
dire une faute politique évidente mais
ce qui est le cas ce n'est pas un
professionnel voilà de la petite
histoire faire cet entretien à ce
journal l'incorrect dont on sait qu'il
est créé c'est le numéro deux il a été
créé par des proches de marion
maréchal-le pen sont plutôt favorables à
un rapprochement en tout cas intacte au
miel entre certaines idées du front
national
il ya à la fois ce qu'il dit il ya
l'endroit aussi où on le dit qui est
important et il ya le moment le faire
avant l'élection
à la tête des républicains dans un
contexte où tous ceux qui sont partis
des républicains essaye de diaboliser
laurent wauquiez qui répète à longueur
de temps sur les chaînes de télévision
de radio et dans les interviews qu'il
n'y aura pas d'accord avec le front
national
et malgré ses propos tous les
constructif essayent de faire croire
qu'il en fera parce que c'est pas clair
et tout ça rajouter un élément de doute
c'était c'est provoquer et du coup
laurent wauquiez n'a pas eu d'autre
choix que de dire ben non je n'y vais
pas et résultat d'ailleurs ils ont
annulé leur leur réunion de dimanche
tout ça effectivement ça montre que
c'est s'était pas maîtrisé françois que
savait la vie à votre avis quelle doit
être la la la feuille de route de la
droite qu'il faut parler pas parler au
front national tendent la main pas tant
de la main ce que je crois c'est que cet
épisode un peu désolant parce
qu'objectivement les problèmes réels de
la france sont bien des égards éloigné
de ses enjeux partisans sur lesquelles
nous nous concentrons de manière
démesurée
maintenant tu vas pas te le dire comment
à ma demande
oui je dirais que l'actualité a tourné
au gré de cette question alors qu'il ya
tellement de choses me semble-t-il plus
consistante à traiter ce qui me semble
en tous les cas c'est que cet épisode a
au moins un mérite c'est de ces de
démontrer qu'il n'y a absolument rien à
attendre de l'illusion d'une union des
droites et pour au moins deux raisons
d'abord parce que le front national est
en pleine explosion c'est très étonnant
de 2,2
d'espérer quelque chose d'un
rapprochement avec ce serait très
étonnant d'espérer quelque chose d'un
rapprochement avec ce parti qui lui
aussi n'a plus de ligne idéologique
claire et puis et puis deuxièmement
parce que de fait
emmanuel macron a eu le génie il faut
bien le dire de comprendre que le
clivage dont nous héritions été dépassé
et plutôt que de s'embarrasser de ces
questions d'appareil il a il a choisi de
2,2 d'offrir une perspective politique
nouvelle il semble que nous sommes un
peu devant le même défi je le crois et
j'avais eu l'occasion de l'écrire dans
vos colonnes pendant l'entre-deux tours
de la présidentielle qu'il n'y a
absolument rien à espérer pour la droite
d'un rapprochement avec le front
national que que le front national ne
sera pas notre avenir ne peut pas l'être
et cet épisode le prouve maintenant ce
qui compte c'est de ceux de réinventer
une proposition politique qui puisse
rassembler une majorité de français sans
se laisser enfermer dans ses danses et
ses histoires d'appareils qui sont de
toute évidence quoi qu'il arrive
absolument absolument stérile on peut
d'ailleurs précisé que la main tendue
était plus vis-à-vis de marion
maréchal-le pen qui elle même est sorti
de l'appareil que vis-à-vis du du front
national lui même eric decouty oui moi
je
si vous permettez je répondrai à
l'excellent carl meeus quand il dit que
il a fait une faute politique
moi je crois pas si faire une faute su
faire de la politique c'est tenir un
discours hypocrite oui il a fait une
faute moi je crois que finalement il a
dit ce qu'il pense et ce qu'il est et ce
qu'il représente je pense qu'il est
cohérent dans l'accident sur le moment
c'est sûr le landeron eux-mêmes que
c'est le bon moment
je pense que c'est le bon moment c'est
le moment où finalement dans un bal de
dupes
eh ben il dit les choses il est très
cohérent avec lui même et là où je
voudrais amour et vous répondre aussi
quand vous parlez de des difficultés du
front national et de l'hymne et man le
front national certes mais la réalité de
la droite aujourd'hui c'est quoi d'autre
qu'un émiettement elle est où la droite
dans sa cohérence on voit bien à la
faveur de cet épisode
à quel point la droite dite classique
elle est partagée divisé en impression
quand même des rivières de sang au sein
même d'un parti qui est de plus en plus
petit de plus en plus étroit et
aujourd'hui ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est peut-être l'enjeu de la
disparition de la droite classique entre
ce mouvement entre sept partis sens
commun de droite qui a évidemment des
relations idéologique des points 2-2
commun avec une partie du front national
fera sur tous les sujets parce qu'on
annonce l'entrée liberia sur kelkoo mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas la ligne philippot
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce à la faveur
ce genre de débat pense que ça plus
d'intérêt que des enjeux d'appareils ces
deux pas de mettre sur la table le débat
des droites ya pas une droite il y en a
pas deux il ya des droites aujourd'hui
qui se recoupent et ça dépasse le débat
idéologique dépasse largement les
frontières anciennes qu'on avait jusqu'à
l'élection présidentielle de mai dernier
en tout cas il ya une stratégie claire
qui est celle de laurent wauquiez qui
donc est l'un des candidats à la
présidence des républicains pour lui la
droite
ça doit être de droite il a affirmé il a
réaffirmé exactement parce que c'est pas
complètement un scoop
hier dans un meeting à saint max
saint-max pour ceux qui ne savent pas
c'est en meurthe et moselle
il ya un élan qui s'est levé et rien ne
nous arrêtera
la droite est de retour la droite est de
retour benjamin granger apparemment les
les sympathisants les républicains sont
plus tôt
en phase avec cette positionnement de
laurent wauquiez un sondage aux hawks a
réalisé pour démettre le consulting que
vous présidez le figaro et france info
nous dit que l'on invoqué le
l'archi-favori archi favori avec presque
78 % des sympathisants les républicains
qui s'ils avaient à voter aujourd'hui
voterai pour lui si maintenant on
élargit sa à l'ensemble des français
c'est encore 44% et il surclasse
l'ensemble de ses concurrents florence
portelli ne recueille 14% et daniel
fasquelle que 4% et en définitive on
voit bien qu'il ya une prime à celui qui
est le plus connu des primes de
notoriété donc pour revenir au sujet qui
nous convient d'aborder la sueur sens
commun quand on regarde sens commun sur
les réseaux sociaux ce que les français
on dise
en fait ils en disent pas grand chose et
sens commun il ya relativement peu de
traces sur les réseaux sociaux on a
connu sens commun au moment finalement
c'est françois fillon qui a un peu à
tort fait connaître sens commun et puis
là on a encore le sujet de sens commun
qui qui revient chaque fois de manière
négative mais avec relativement peu de
traces donc de toute façon personne n'a
intérêt à parler de sens commun et en
premier lieu laurent wauquiez qui est
archi favori
archi-favori qui toute façon on a n'a
qu'un intérêt c'est à ne pas tomber dans
le péché d'orgueil évidemment parce que
l'élection elle et elle est qu'en
décembre
et c'est l'élection des militants et non
pas simplement des français et surtout
de ne prendre aucun risque aucun risque
avec avec ce qui semble être une
victoire assurée car mais sauvé la
statique laurent wauquiez c'est
peut-être de s'inspirer largement décidé
de sens commun sans pour autant sa fiche
et oui c'est ça c'est le sparadrap du
capitaine haddock il essaye de se
débarrasser d'un sparadrap qu'on lui
colle sur l'accord avec le front
national
et là il ya sens commun qui essayent de
venir coller un autant d emblée 6 y
regarder on va voir non il en veut pas
il n'a pas besoin comme vous l'avez dit
il va dérouler sa campagne
il essaye de ne pas faire l'erreur de
françois fillon en 2012 au moment de la
conquête des républicains qui se
disaient voilà les sondages me donne à
peu près d'ailleurs ces chiffres-là 80%
c'est tranquille je vais pouvoir ne pas
faire campagne et résultats
jean françois copé lui faisait campagne
donc ils sont arrivés à touche touche
sans arriver à toucher toutes les
grandes élections
d'autres possibilités on évoque lui tout
ça là il y aura un vote électronique
le 10 ans mais surtout laurent wauquiez
fait campagne il était en meurthe et
moselle il va dans tous les départements
parce qu'il sait c'est important de
parler aux militants sous-comité moi je
pense que c'est une stratégie qui va
permettre à laurent wauquiez de gagner
mais je pense que cette stratégie là
elle est suicidaire pour la droite parce
qu'à force ne pas évoquer les débats de
fond
la droite se perdre dans l'absence de
débat il y avait un sondage un autre
sondage se croit cette semaine chez vous
ou ailleurs je ne sais plus qui disait
que 60% des sympathisants de droite
étaient pour une solidarité pour un
soutien pour les gardes emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas ce que la
droite pense oui on a des droites qui
pensent différents différemment mais il
ya on n'a pas de discours et de débats
me semble-t-il sur le fond pas si vous
êtes d'accord avec moi mais c'est
dramatique
et tant qu'on ne parlera que des
logiques d'appareil temps caen voudra
mettre sous le boisseau le débat de fond
eh bien je pense que la droite se perdre
al'avantage entièrement d'accord avec
vous sur ce point et de fait la seule
question qui se pose c'est de savoir ce
que nous appelons des débats de fond la
question du rapprochement avec le front
national ou du cepas ce n'est pas
vraiment ce que j'appellerais débat de
fond c'est à dire que les vrais débats
de fond c'est qu'est ce que la droite a
à proposer en face de la proposition d'
emmanuel macron et de fait on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la droite est totalement
désorienté déboussolée elle a commencé
cette cette crise intérieure avec
le passage à mon sens du programme des
présidentielles au programme des
législatives d'un seul coup en sabrant
50% de sa proposition pour les
présidentielles au moment des
législatives
maintenant la droite ne sait plus ce
qu'elle a à offrir elle est profondément
profondément divisée et il nous semble
qu'elle ne se reconstruira qu'en
repartant au fond des choses
ça fait ce qu'elle a à offrir la droite
dès lors qu emmanuel macron fait en gros
la politique en tout cas économique que
la droite avait promis
d'abord je je ne suis pas absolument sûr
qu'il maniait macron face contrairement
aux idées reçues la politique que la
droite avait promis d' y compris sur le
plan économique
et je crois qu emmanuel macron encore
une fois a eu le mérite de secouer un
débat démocratique qui était épuisée qui
était en quelque sorte périmés il me
semble que ce débat nous en héritions en
quelque sorte depuis le mur de berlin il
s'est structuré à l'ombre du clivage est
ouest est en fait il ne correspond pas
aux enjeux du 21e siècle et dans ceux
dans ce dans ce face à ces enjeux du 21e
siècle
il ya deux grandes questions qui vont
émerger on le voit déjà dans la
politique de manuel mâcon ya la question
de l'europe et donc la question de la
souveraineté et la suite je pense que la
droite doit avoir des choses à dire il
ya la question du rapport aux progrès du
rapport aux progrès c'est à dire à la
science à la technologie à l'irruption
ou à l'invasion de ces de ces questions
dans nos dans notre quotidien dans la
vie indique armand incident par exemple
et sur ces sujets là il faut absolument
que la droite sache se réinventer et
c'est nécessaire d'abord pour elle en
quelque sorte mais c'est aussi et
surtout nécessaire pour l'équilibré du
débat démocratique français parce que si
la droite mais il n'y parvient pas le
grand danger est que emmanuel macron
comme ça semble être malheureusement son
rêve et c'est une faute politique assez
grave de sa part je crois ne finisse par
être isolé avec la bonne gestion au
milieu et les extrêmes partout autour
ce qui me paraît être évidemment il
le symptôme d'une crise démocratique
très profonde et non pas une solution
pour notre pays
j'ai vu laurent wauquiez justement cette
semaine donc ça permette par rapport à
ce qu'il a dit de donner deux anecdotes
pour répondre à ce que disait le
président de coty il après l'élection il
or il sera élu normalement pour quatre
ans donc là il va avoir le temps le
temps avec l'équipe qui la met en place
pour renouveler un certain nombre
d'idées je prends juste un exemple
notamment sur l'écologie il veut
réfléchir à une écologie
qu'ils soient de droite c'est à dire qui
ne soit pas une écologie punitive avec
on augmente les taxes ou on punit ceux
qui roulent au diesel là mais on trouve
ce que vous évoquez avec le progrès avec
d'autres éléments peut-être là une
conception d'écologie droite sur le
social aussi il prenait l'exemple
l'autre jour il était à belfort il a
rencontré des ouvriers d'alstom
jean la cgt dé du atouts qui disent
aimer l'autre façon ils ne nous aiment
pas l'autre sa cible et emmanuel macron
donc là il ya peut-être pour la droite
aussi à rechercher toutes ses classes
populaires les ouvriers les salariés des
classes populaires qui ont déserté la
drogue depuis 2007 alors que c'était des
gens qui avaient voté pour nicolas
sarkozy il ya un discours là alors
visiblement on va voir on jugera sur
pièce mais laurent wauquiez a l'air
assez décidé à agir là dessus et
elisabeth grenat semble être d'accord
avec vous puisque nous dit la droite
doit être à droite et c'est tout c'est
ce que nous attendions sinon pour qui
voter benjamin gans encore un mois ce
sont ces sujets oui sur le dans le
sondage qu'on a sorti cette semaine il y
avait aussi une question sur l'enjeu
c'est à dire sur la manière dont les
sympathisants et l'air et les français
considéré cette élection considérée
cette élection des républicains 56%
aujourd'hui des sympathisants considère
que c'est un vrai enjeu car c'est le
président du principal parti
d'opposition qui sera élu et c'est quand
même 36 % de l'ensemble des français
c'est pour dire que cette derrière là
comment dire derrière la question qu'on
soulève
il ya toute la question évidemment du
débat de fond et comme on a parmi les
quatre candidats trois d'entre eux qui
totalise 20% simplement
aujourd'hui des intentions de vote ils
auront tout intérêt pour se faire
connaître
finalement à débattre sur le fond d'un
certain nombre de sujets sains pour
accroître leur notoriété
et deuxième chose pour être sûr qu'il
soit entendu zelaya
florence portelli parmi ces candidats à
la présidence de deux des républicains
devraient vous faire réagir à une
déclaration qu'il a faite ce matin sur
france info laurent wauquiez donc autres
candidats a refusé de débattre avec
marine le pen dans l'émission politique
l'émission de france 2 à laquelle il
avait été convié la semaine prochaine
pour la candidate florence portelli
c'est une erreur écoutez je trouve
dommage qu'il n'ait pas voulu débattre
face à marine le pen
qu'avait-il à perdre on va venir
moi j'y serais allée est d'ailleurs moi
j'ai toujours une ligne très claire de
c'est peut-être pour ça que j'ai jamais
est invité à prendre le café avec ces
gens là voilà l'erreur c'est pas de
débattre avec marine le pen cède pas
vouloir débattre avec marine le pen
une réaction là dessus vous qui a eu
raison il a eu tort c'est une bouillie
évidemment que c'est une erreur que je
comprends pas il me semblait que c'était
alors j'ai pas entendu ses arguments qui
justifient son île on n'est pas sans
briller mais dans leur intérêt qui va
aller parler aux français
je pense que ça alors on peut
l'interpréter de différentes façons pour
l'interpréter comme la peur justement la
veille d'une élection de montrer qu'il
ya trop de deux passerelles possibles je
ne comprends pas je ne comprends pas
cette absence
aujourd'hui il me semblait que marine le
pen était considéré par l'ensemble de la
classe politique comme faisant partie de
l'arc aux républicains et qu'on
débattait avec elle non pro 2e tour
élection présidentielle et dans les
débats de la première
je ne comprends pas la stratégie de
laurent wauquiez alors je comprends trop
bien je vous pouvez cameron ne résiste
pas non
françois-xavier bellamy nous parlait
tout à l'heure des des sujets de fond le
sujet de société et bien un beau sujet
sous les apparences un peu technique
c'est les allocations familiales avec le
principe c'est que les allocations
familiales elles sont universelles c'est
à dire que on les touche en fonction du
nombre d'enfants que l'on a
indépendamment de ses revenus
françois hollande en 2015 est déjà
revenu en partie sur cette universalité
en gros plus vous étiez riches - vous
touchez d'allocations aujourd'hui la
question qui se pose au sein de la
majorité c'est est ce qu'on les supprime
ou non pour les riches et bien figurez
vous que quelqu'un qui est contre et
c'est laurent berger le secrétaire
général de la cfdt il l'a dit ce matin
sur europe 1 et ça m'intéresserait
d'avoir votre réaction
une fois qu'on aura écoutez nous on est
attaché au principe d'universalité
je crois qu'il faut quand on veut pour
une raison simple pas simplement pour
les aides qui peuvent parfois paraître
dérisoire au regard des revenus des uns
et des autres c'est on est dans un
système de solidarité si vous voulez des
systèmes collectifs on a décidé ensemble
d'avoir des droits parce qu'on se à ce
qu'on s'assure mutuellement et si on
commence à l'être des brèches dans le
fait que certains pourraient payer mais
ne pas bénéficier de cette universalité
ou de ses droits
eh bien vous verrez qu'à un moment donné
ces mêmes personnes diront moi j'arrête
de j'arrête de jouer je vois des regards
approbateurs moi je suis absolument
d'accord je trouve ça un sens et même
qu'on ait pu l'envisager
sauf que le principe de l'universalité
ce que dit laurent berger parfaitement
juste appartement où vont les corn oil
écorche les cornes c'est fini donc mais
il me semble que la question est réglée
si j'ai bien compris le groupe la
république en marche a décidé de
s'opposer à l'éventuelle roulement
j'espère que ce serait bien embêté il ya
un parlementaire qui a été nommé et qui
va rendre ses conclusions en décembre
matignon a commandé un rapport donc
c'est reculer pour mieux sauter d'autant
qu'on sait qu'à bercy il ya bruno le
maire qu'il est il très favorable depuis
longtemps à cette suppression sur le
jugement l'argument de dire ben moi j'en
ai pas besoin
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
pour les hauts revenus c'est quoi ces 60
euros ça dépend du nombre d'enfants si
vous avez deux enfants et vous gagnez
plus de 7400 87 euros il vous reste 32
euros d'allocations et c'est loin de
l'univers des rues je veux pas parler
trop longtemps mais au début on parlait
de la morale il ya des principes et je
pense que notre système il fonctionne
autour de principes là qui sont actés et
je pense que les principes auxquels on
ne touche pas tandis qu'est ce qu'on en
dit long mais jo alors on en dit
majoritairement deux choses la première
c'est que le point finalement dû cette
universalité et du fait que les plus
aisés n'auraient plus droit à ce type de
système c'est très bien acceptée tout le
monde le comprend ça c'est le premier
point est le deuxième point c'est que si
on regarde
finalement ce que l'on dit dans les sept
derniers jours c'est pour vous donner le
commandant le le niveau d'intérêt que la
population y porte on peut noter 443
mille messages sur allocations
familiales dans les sept derniers jours
c'est à dire rien et 15000 sur les
forums c'est à dire très faibles donc en
d'autres termes les français sont passés
à autre chose
on en a parlé peut-être ya quinze jours
où il ya quinze jours ou trois semaines
quand eux il y avait eu ce débat
maintenant ils sont passés à autre chose
bon à la marque a besoin maintenant
c'est sympa de cas c'est comme ça qu'ils
n'intéressent pas les français mais non
en fait c'est par mais je ne sais pas
que c'est parce que vous pensez on a
raison si intéressant en fait vous avez
raison de remettre le sujet sur la table
merci beaucoup pour me rassurer
françois-xavier la vie qu'est ce que
vous dites aux français qui disent c'est
pas un sujet l'érection pas besoin de ça
on peut comprendre que des gens
réagissent comme ça mais en réalité il
se joue quelque chose je suis d'accord
avec vous
du point de vue des principes qui est
extrêmement extrêmement décisif la
politique familiale en france a été
conçu pour être une politique familiale
et non pas une politique sociale c'est à
dire que les allocations familiales ne
correspondent pas à l'exercice d'une
solidarité envers les plus les plus
démunis il ya d'autres dispositifs qui
existent pour ça la politique familiale
a pour but d'accompagner toutes les
familles dans la l accompagnement de
deux de leurs enfants qui on le sait
représente un effort important en termes
de temps et en terme de budget pour pour
de très nombreux foyers et donc c'est
une façon pour le pour la société de
manifester sa présence aux côtés de ceux
qui assurent son avenir et je crois que
si on revenait sur le principe
personnalité des allocations familiales
en réalité on ferait changer de sens
la signification même on basculerait
dans une autre dans une politique d'une
autre nature
et là pour le coup on parlait tout à
l'heure de ces débats de fond sur
lesquels peut se reconstruire le clivage
démocratique là je crois qu'il ya une
vraie ligne de fracture
emmanuel macron on l'a montré pendant la
campagne le considère que l'horizon de
la politique c'est l'émancipation de
l'individu à travers des mesures comme
l'individualisation de l'impôt sur le
revenu qui est toujours aussi dans l'air
à travers une vision finalement très
très individualiste delà de la 2d
parcours et des itinéraires personnels
emmanuel macron qui poursuit en cela
l'oeuvre de françois hollande est en
train de détricoter l'idée même de ceux
de cette construction familiale sur
laquelle je crois il faut que aussi bien
des gens comme laurent berger et qui ou
des gens qui sont issus de la gauche que
deux personnes qui sont issus de la
droite puissent se mobiliser pour faire
savoir que la société est plus qu'une
juxtaposition d'individus et que les
liens qui unissent les personnes
notamment dans la constitution d'une
famille méritent d'être reconnus par la
société d'être accompagné par elle et se
joue en fait dans ce débat sur les
allocations familiales touche vraiment à
une vision globale de la société et
c'est une bifurcation assez décisif dans
laquelle nous sommes placés et en même
temps quand même si j'étais au pouvoir
je me dirai pour faire passer la pilule
du démantèlement des s est fait de la
baisse de l'impôt sur le capital
considérés comme des cadeaux aux riches
et ben je suis prime universelles
utilisées allocations familiales toute
façon les gens concernés font beaucoup
plus d'économie d'impôt ont beaucoup
plus à gagner avec ma politique qu'ils
ont à perdre avec la suppression et puis
c'est un moyen de montrer que je ne suis
pas le président des riches tels qu'on
m'a collé cette étiquette depuis le
début du quinquennat et donc au fond ont
montré que je touche là aux riches
ce qu'a montré d'ailleurs un article du
figaro aussi en montrant qu'il y avait
eu à la 5 millions de personnes aisées
qui ont qui vont être touchés ça permet
de rééquilibrer un petit peu
politiquement ça sa majorité
en même temps il faut faire très
attention parce qu'on parle des riches
et vous si deezer des niveaux de revenus
qui sont très élevés ou est en réalité
ce qui risque d'être touché par les
mesures de cette nature c'est encore la
classe moyenne celle qui va payer la
taxe d'habitation
les deux premiers déciles qui vont
continuer de payer la taxe d'habitation
qui subissent eux aussi la hausse de la
csg et qui ne bénéficient pas des
politiques de redistribution est donc là
on se retrouve aussi devant une
injustice fiscale et sociale qui est de
plus en plus grande et qui risque de
briser le consensus ou le consentement à
la participation à la solidarité est ce
que disait laurent berger très justement
cette classe moyenne qui fait
effectivement l'objet de la couverture
du fin de la une du figaro quotidien de
ce matin parce qu' elle n'est pas assez
riche pour pour supporter la suppression
pour profiter plutôt du démantèlement de
l'usf même est trop riche pour profiter
d'un certain nombre de baisses d'impôts
hérités coûte il y avait un autre
argument schaeffler engagé qui était de
dire attention c'est le consentement à
l'impôt qui risque de disparaître si les
allocations sont toujours pour les mêmes
bien sûr je pense que c'est c'est en ce
sens qu'on dit c'est que c'est des
principes c'est extrêmement dangereux je
pense que le fait que les gens c'est
bien que vous en parliez s'est bien
débattu de ce sujet là parce que je
trouve que l'ange les enjeux au delà de
la symbolique de la petite politique
nous avez raison car de souligner qu' il
ya une dimension politicienne de basse
politique en quelque sorte de der garde
et on va prendre aux riches
je pense que les enjeux autour de cette
question là sont beaucoup plus lourds
que ce qu'on veut bien laisser entendre
et que effectivement c'est selon des
principes qui peuvent être écornée et
l'a déjà à l'impôt en fait partie je
vous soumets une réaction sur les
réseaux sociaux de daniel sicot sur
notre site internet plus exactement
doit-on continuer à mener une politique
fiscale et des aides aussi généreuse
alors qu'on nous prédit pour les années
à venir une natalité explosive et que
cette politique entraîne chez certains
un moyen supplémentaire d'arrondir les
fins de mois sans se préoccuper de
l'avenir de leurs enfants
bah voila je laisse cette remarque à
votre à votre réflexion et je propose de
passer un dernier sujet qui va sûrement
nous valoir un grand nombre de
protestations pas totalement injustifiée
il s'agit de l'égalité homme-femme et de
la parité ce plateau soit n'est pas très
paritaire pour tout vous dire il était
prévu qu'on est une femme parmi nous
mais c'est pas parce que il ya cinq
hommes autour de cette table qu'on n'a
pas le droit de parler de ce sujet
muriel pénicaud ministre du travail a
présenté avec sa collègue madame scapa
secrétaire d'état à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes mais j'y suis
parvenu
un guide de l'égalité hommes-femmes dans
les tpe pme et page 24 de ce guide
il y à cette recommandation user du
féminin et du masculin dans vos discours
à l'oral comme à l'écrit
chaque fois que vous parlez de personnes
pour que chacun et chacune puisse se
sentir concerné point e par votre
passage dit les clientes et les clients
les agentes et les agents vous pouvez
simplifiée merci beaucoup
les clientes point e s les agents point
e s les professionnels point s de la
restauration
eric decouty c est un gadget ce genre de
proposition ou ce qu'on appelle
l'écriture inclusive c'est un progrès
que dire que dire je trouve je vais vous
dire je trouve ça profondément dérisoire
il ya des vrais sujets sur le traitement
fait aux femmes
aujourd'hui il ya des vrais sujets aux
états unis qui touche l'ensemble de la
société
je pense que la place des femmes est
très réducteur de lits ou douala je
pense qu'elle est vrai sujet c'est un
vrai sujet la place des femmes dans la
société
je pense que le lin cris de l'écriture
inclusive mais je vais peut-être me
faire tomber dessus par tous mes
camarades je trouve ça assez dérisoire
benjamin grands ça aussi c'est un sujet
dans les gens parlent peu en fait on en
parle beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
et on le voit un élément qui est la
popularité des différents ministres sur
sur la toile on s'aperçoit que le
troisième ministre qui est dont on parle
le plus c'est marlène chape ya juste
après edouard philippe et gérard collomb
et à travers ça comme dans son
portefeuille c'est l'égalité
c'est l'égalité hommes femmes évidemment
c'est un sujet qui amène bonne chose
alors pour rebondir sur ce que vous
évoquez sur le l'écriture inclusive
il ya aussi un deuxième deuxième sujet
c'est finalement l'égalité de traitement
médiatique alors si on prend un sujet
qui est le par exemple le la nomination
du conseil national du numérique
on nous dit ce ne sera pas un président
ce sera une présidente est ce que
véritablement présenté comme sain c'est
valorisant on aurait pu plutôt évoquer
les critères sur lesquels ce choix se
fait évoquer le parcours des candidats
ou des candidates
bref je pense pas que ça aurait été un
homme on aurait parlé de la même manière
et donc à travers st je trouve que voilà
ne jouons pas du gadget
essayons de travailler vraiment dans le
fonds et d'avoir aidé à voir une comment
dire une vraie logique valorisante du
sujet françois que vous avez là mais
qu'est ce que le professeur en prépa
littéraire pense de l'écriture inclusive
ça c'est un sujet qui peut paraître
effectivement dérisoire ou anecdotique
mais qui à mon avis il est beaucoup
moins qu'on ne pourrait l'imaginer mais
pour une raison assez simple c'est qu'en
fait ce type de rapport au langage est
toujours le symptôme d'une forme
d'idéologie c'est à dire que l'on
regarde juste un exemple un les aînés on
décrira à l'avenir les étudiant.es
diplômés point e s en littérature je
vous ai interrompu par dont m
en fait derrière ça derrière ce type de
mesures est derrière les injonctions qui
sont fait d'utiliser des graphiques
d'ailleurs ne sont pas aujourd'hui les
graphies normal de l'orthographe
française tels que l'adm l académie
française par exemple
derrière cette injonction il ya l'idée
qu'on va transformer le monde parle le
langage serre que la transformation du
rapport aux mots va finir par changer
les mentalités et donc il ya une forme
de deux il ya un regard très
manipulateur sur les consciences
l'idée étant de d'imposer une
transformation des représentations du
monde à travers la langue corse qui est
ce qui est problématique dans cette
inquiétude que l'orthographe inclusive
porte avec elle c'est un soupçon
permanent sur l'inégalité comme si au
fond il fallait arracher de la langue
tout ce qui pourrait rester un soupçon
d'illégalité
cela étant dit cette inégalité fait
l'objet d'une attention très
asymétriques parce que je suis d'accord
avec vous il ya beaucoup de
sujet qui touche aux violences qui sont
faites aux femmes aujourd'hui je le dis
comme enseignant dans beaucoup de nos
établissements scolaires il ya une très
grande souffrance vécue par les jeunes
filles à cause de ce que précisément
malheureusement des cultures populaires
qui sont accessibles à des jeunes qui
ont d'autres problèmes d'orthographe que
ce qu'on est en train de discuter
aujourd'hui peuvent peuvent véhiculer
avec eux ses souffrances que beaucoup de
jeunes filles portent ne seront pas
traitées par ce type de réforme en
revanche ce qui nous est instillé
progressivement c'est l'idée qu' il
faudrait arraché de notre culture tout
ce qui pourrait introduire une forme de
différenciation de distinction et ça
n'est qu'une étape d'autres étapes
suivront jusqu'à une espèce de folie
parce qu'en réalité la langue porte avec
elle la culture dans sa globalité porte
avec elle la distinction du masculin et
du féminin
je voudrais prendre un autre exemple qui
est très éloigné c'est la polémique
récente que jean luc mélenchon a lancé
sur le drapeau européen et on se dit le
drapeau européen porte avec lui une
symbolique religieuse
donc il faudrait arraché symbolique
religieuse goya ça ne s'arrêtera maubleu
couleurs de la sainte vierge avec les
douze étoiles qu'on me mets parfois
autour de la vierge d'un de ses
représentations et donc il s'agit de
transformer la culture pour changer le
monde mais en fait et cette révolte
contre la culture ne s'arrête nulle part
il n'y a pas de points d'arrêt on n'aura
jamais fini de défaire tout ce qui
pourrait paraître les gauchers enlever
le blanc du drapeau bleu blanc rouge
parce qu'il rappelle la monarchie et
donc et même le bleu marine c'est un
sainte geneviève et et saint-martin donc
on en vient à une ville rouge tellement
taux de saint martin là je crois qu'on
devrait être capable de dire travaillons
pour changer nos comportements en vue
d'une véritable justice entre les
employés entre les hommes et les femmes
et il ya beaucoup à faire sur le sujet
il faudrait que notre indignation ne
soit pas à géométrie variable mais en
revanche ne tentons pas de faire évoluer
la société par des manipulations langue
agir laissons le langage se transformer
et vivre sa propre vie au gré de ses de
ces transformations de la société adt
mes choix c'est un peu comme si quand on
veut traiter preuve du racisme anti plus
qu'il ya des gens qui sont noirs ou
maghrébins en dix issus de la diversité
sortes de stratégies d'évitement des
sujets par le langage
oui moi j'ai l'impression de voir
souvent ce que vous dites que le langage
est ce que il évolue parce qu'il ya une
décision politique
donc j'ai lu le formidable libre examen
le moenner
sur mistral qui parle comment est-ce que
les indices le langage a évolué parce
qu'on a dit commencer à dire des gros
mots mais le langage jeu par le
professeur la question il évolue parce
que on le fait évoluer
est ce que il évolue parce qu'à une
décision politique qui décide je n'ai
pas l'impression en fait engagé puisse
évoluer comme ça il ya des mots qu'il
faisait là il ya 2 il ya deux façons de
voir les choses c'est à dire soit on
admet que la société vivre sa propre vie
et que ce soit dans la lah le
foisonnement des interactions que le
langage se transforme et qu'il exprime
la réalité du monde que nous voulons
créer soit on considère au contraire
mais il me semble qu'il ya là un geste
qui est en fait intrinsèquement
totalitaire que il faut que le politique
centralise une décision qui en passant
par le langage change notre rapport au
réel
et là pour le coup il ya quelque chose
de potentiellement très dangereux qui
nous rappelle la novlangue orwellienne
si vous voulez je ne dis pas par là que
le gouvernement d' emmanuel macron soit
totalitaires dans son essence mais il ya
là une tentation qui me paraît très
grave parce que au lieu de 2,2 respecter
cette maturation propres de la société
et de faire en sorte que nos
comportements plus tendre vers la
justice
on prétend changer notre rapport au réel
par la médiation du langage car maïs on
l'a vu si emmanuel macron cette
tentation quand il dit tout et tous
quand est ce que c'est ça c'est un jeu
c'est à dire un tic de langage parce que
ce serait désobligeant mais est ce que
c'est une habitude qui gagne la classe
politique
j'ai pas l'impression que je qu'à droite
on est repris ce type de langage la 2d
manuel macron moi ce qui me frappe
surtout c'est dans le texte c'est les
deux ministres disent pour simplifier
mais quand vous voyez la façon de ces
écrits vous ne voyez pas du tout la
simplification étudiant.es je mets au
défi
[Musique]
les enfants dans les écoles ou les
lycéens de trouver que c'est plus simple
que d'écrire avant les étudiants je
remarque que les filles impliquées à ce
moment là effectivement on transforme le
mariage est une espèce de maurs c'est un
peu un petit peu surprenant que c'est
surtout que les enjeux sur la violence
faite aux femmes ne sont pas là je ne
dis pas que c'est pas important mais il
ya d'autres enjeux qui méritent de
d'être débattue et d'être combattue oui
vous êtes là on est un petit peu
peut-être dans effectivement dans le
dans la quintessence du politiquement
correct
et quand christine lagarde directrice
générale du fonds monétaire
international se plaint qu'il n'y ait
pas assez de femmes parmi les prix nobel
de l'économie est ce que ça vous paraît
une protestation justifiez vous aggravez
votre cas vous le dire en fait ce qui
est en jeu de manière vraiment décisif
c'est le fait que chacun dans notre
société dans nos sociétés puissent avoir
accès au destin qu'il se choisit ça pour
le coup ça me paraît fondamental et je
crois que de ce point de vue là nous
avons des préoccupations majeures
apportées concernant la refondation de
notre école parce qu'aujourd'hui notre
école est devenue terriblement
inégalitaire et elle est à l'eau à
l'origine d'une profonde injustice
sociale faire en sorte que chaque enfant
puisse accéder au destin qu'il se
choisit sa pour le quid d'une façon
certaine ceux de ce devrait être notre
objectif commun maintenant ce qui est
derrière cette désolation
c'est peut-être aussi autre chose la
question et faudrait-il que pour que
nous considérions que les femmes sont
enfin libérés
chacun se dirigent de façon identique
vers toutes les vers toutes les voies où
toutes les formations aux touts les
carrières possibles pour le coup la
question qui est posée derrière cette
expression c'est la question que portent
les études de genre qu'y at-il de
culturel qui at-il peut-être de naturel
dans la diversité de nos de nos de nos
attentions de nos curiosités de nos
envies de nos talents ça pour le coup il
me semble que à titre personnel nous
avons suffisamment appris et
heureusement à nous réjouir de la
diversité pour tenter de l'écraser là
encore par une forme de
d'obligations qui serait fait en
particulier aux femmes d'adopter
désormais des carrières qui était jusque
là considérée comme structurellement
masculine merci beaucoup monsieur
l'intelligence de vos récentes je trouve
que ces sujets n'étaient pas aussi à
double si que qu'il n'y paraissait merci
à tous les quatre nous retrouvons où
nous nous retrouvons oui lundi prochain
pour un prochain point de vue toujours
sur fear alive même heure même endroit
et surtout restez connectés dans
quelques minutes le précision les états
unis donald trump va rendre son verdict
sur l'accord que les états unis avaient
signé mais c'était son prédécesseur
barack obama l'accord historique censé
empêcher l'iran de se doter de l'arme
nucléaire
cette décision est extrêmement attendu
elle peut avoir un impact considérable
sur le les tensions éventuelles dans les
relations internationales tout de suite
vous allez retrouver le décryptage
d'isabelle lasserre qui est spécialiste
de ces questions au figaro dans le focus
du jour avec ariane le coeur merci
beaucoup à lundi
[Musique]